senator catherine cortez masto also  campaigning around the valley today she  visited with teamsters and valet  attendance to discuss her efforts to  fight for nevada's working families as  well as organized labor unions cortez  masto's dad was a teamster he had to  start parking cars she says she's  leading the charge to fight for our  state's workers  this is the backbone of our industry  these are the workers that make us look  good here in las vegas when all these  millions of tourists come and we need to  make sure that we've got their backs  senator cortez masto says she'll  continue her work to lower costs for  nevada families by pushing to bring down  health care costs and holding oil  companies responsible for high gas  prices in particular now under the  heavyweight of course of inflation